ah okay good morning John two years
before you email me and told me that it
was a good idea to make a bunch of weird
video blogs and a weird new platform
called YouTube you published your first
book a book that did the thing that
books like it don't really do that often
not only was it a book about like real
people in the real world that did okay
it kept doing okay and in fact kept
doing better now that book that is 13
years old is being turned into an
eight-episode miniseries on Hulu no
we're not gonna get movie it's better
than a movie because there's more of it
I know that you been waiting for this
for a very long time and I'm I'm really
excited and really hat I just want to
watch it and this is a reminder of
something I've learned several times
over the 38 years that it took to become
a 38 year old you never know how things
are gonna go and you don't know when a
hard work is gonna pay off and also you
don't know if it's gonna pay off it
might never but it also might just take
a while last week I was at the YouTube
creator summit which is where YouTube
flies a bunch of youtubers to a fancy
hotel and then we yell at him basically
it was a little bit expecting to be seen
as like what I am which is like yet like
old and useless and yesterday's news
look I'm not done about this I got a
book it's very exciting crash course and
scishow we're doing amazingly well it's
season 12 here on vlogbrothers and that
like in TV that doesn't happen and I'm
fully aware the people who are getting
popular on YouTube right now are often
like making feature films seven days a
week to make it on this platform but I'm
sitting here for the same bookshelf I
was sitting in front of backwards shot
II was pulling on her apple bottom jeans
and the furry boots for the first time
how is this still working
I'm not asking question but at this
point I know next to nothing about how
to get popular on YouTube know that it's
hard I know that it's rare I know that
when it happens it's not because you had
a really great idea or you really worked
your butt off or you got really lucky or
you had access to resources or knowledge
that other people didn't have access to
it's because all of those things
happened at the same time I don't have
any special knowledge the last time I
created a YouTube channel from scratch
smartphones didn't exist oh God but I do
know about some of the mistakes that
I've made and that other creators have
made I know a little bit about what to
do and not do once you start to have an
audience and also I know what to do when
you realize that maybe that's not going
to last forever this is a fantastic job
that I love and that I want as many
people as possible to have but the highs
can be very high and the lows can be
very low
on YouTube and really all social media
you got these numbers right down here
always telling you how many people are
watching how many people like that how
many people didn't like it because
they're so objective and concrete it's
very easy to let those numbers take over
is a kind of surrogate for how much you
matter but what goes up must come down
and here on vlogbrothers we've seen
enough up and down and up and down do
not have our self-worth so tied up in
getting to this point was a process I
worry a lot about younger creators both
big and small but I also have a lot of
hope I think a greater and greater
percentage of people are gonna be able
to be professional creators because of
the fracturing of Fame because of the
rise of new patronage models on that
path there's a lot of pitfalls and
anything that I can do personally to
make that easier for other people that
stuff I want to do and I honestly hope
that that becomes a bigger and bigger
part of my professional life and because
they like this job so much if I can help
other people have it and help them have
it in a productive way that is healthy
that's like the best possible outcome
for because part of why I'm headed to
VidCon very soon if your community track
the signing lottery is open right now
and it's gonna be closing so just wanted
to mention that so if you want to get
into any of the signings you need to buy
tickets very soon I'm working on my
Creator track talk which is part of why
I've been thinking about this stuff so
much but it's hard to have advice that
works for everybody because all kinds of
creators are so different from each
other but here's a little bit a Hulu
series that is very very cool and it is
something that happens to basically know
what John nothing you and I have ever
done is as good as finding joy in making
stuff and finding a great community to
make it inside of and also maybe finding
a little bit of faith in humanity John
congratulations for real I'll see you on
Tuesday this is the end screen song
Jason Derulo